cuál es la utilidad real de estas
resoluciones si después de la primera
que mencionábamos igual la guerra
continuó
en primer lugar algunas noches para
aclarar es un gusto enorme
el rol de la onu en este momento es uno
de condena si obviamente cualquier
acción que se tome tiene que ser desde
la asamblea general y no desde el
consejo de seguridad por el obvio motivo
de que cualquier política o resolución
que intente aplicarse desde el consejo
de seguridad va a ser frenada
evidentemente por rusia e incluso
también quizás por china si es que
decide abstenerse que vemos que ha sido
el caso en numerosas veces
es por esto que la asamblea general en
ese sentido vemos que sirve como una
especie de condena a nivel internacional
que es envía un mensaje que es muy claro
también a nivel internacional y que de
alguna forma aísla a rusia y a sus
aliados frente a una situación que es
claramente
condenatoria sino que de condenables
disculpe
lamentablemente vemos que este es el
alcance que tiene hasta ahora la
asamblea general y no vemos que lleve a
mayores y vemos que también ucrania
presenta críticas en función de la
resolución y de los votos de la
resolución porque tomar acción o aprobar
resoluciones no necesariamente implica
que la situación cambie para ucrania y
como ustedes mencionó el veto de rusia
impide que el consejo de seguridad de la
onu adopte una resolución similar y de
hecho fue por eso que llegó a la
asamblea pero jurídica y políticamente
cuál es la diferencia de que la asamblea
general adopte el documento en vez de
que lo haga el consejo de seguridad
la diferencia principal es que no es
vinculante es decir
para hablar en términos simples el
consejo de seguridad aprueba una
resolución es vinculante significa que
lo que se dice se hace a priori
con respecto a la asamblea general
pueden aprobar resoluciones pero sólo
aquellos estados que estén de acuerdo en
implementar dicha resolución son los que
van a llevar adelante lo que es la
resolución plantea no es que tiene una
acción vinculante como sí lo tiene el
caso del consejo de seguridad y si las
resoluciones de la asamblea no son
vinculantes entonces que podría parar el
avance ruso muy breve
muy brevemente yo creo que lo único que
puede parar en este momento el avance de
ruso es que se siente en tanto silencio
y como putin en una mesa de negociación
y que decidan cuáles son los puntos en
los cuales ucrania está dispuesto a
ceder porque lamentablemente eso creo
que es lo único que frenaría en este
momento el avance ruso y que pondría fin
a la parte bélica si se quiere del
conflicto